we know that when we're just multiplying
regular numbers we have the notion of a
reciprocal for example if i were to take
2 and i were to multiply it by its
reciprocal it would be equal to 1. or if
i were to just take a and a is not equal
to 0 and i were to multiply it by its
reciprocal for any a that is not equal
to 0 this will also be equal to 1. and
this is a number that if i multiply it
times anything
i am just going to get that original
number so that's interesting put it in
the back of our minds you learned this
many many years ago now we also have
something that comes out of our
knowledge of functions we know that if
there's some function
let's call it f of x
that goes from some set we call that our
domain
to some other set we call that our range
that in many cases not all cases so this
is the function f that goes from x
to f of x
that in many cases but not all time not
always the case there's another function
that can take us back
and we call that other function the
inverse of f
so that if you apply the inverse of f to
f of x you're going to get back to where
you were you're going to get back to x
and we also know that it goes the other
way around for example if you did f of
f inverse of x
f inverse of x that 2 will get us back
to x
so the natural question is is there an
analog for an inverse of a function or
for reciprocal when we're multiplying
when we think about
matrices
so let's play with a few ideas so let's
imagine a matrix as a transformation
which is which we have already talked
about when we think about matrices as
transformations they really are
functions they're functions that are
taking one point in a certain
dimensional space let's say in the
coordinate plane to another point it
transforms a vector to another vector
for example
let's imagine something that does a
clockwise
90 degree rotation and we know how to
construct that transformation matrix
which really is a function
what it does is in our transformation
matrix we want to say what do we do with
the
1 0
unit vector
and what also do we do with the
0 1 unit vector when you do that
transformation
well if you're doing a 90 degree
clockwise turn then the 1 0 unit vector
is going to go right over here
and so that's going to be turned into
the
0 negative 1 vector so we'll write that
right there and then the 0 1 vector is
going to be turned into the 1 0 vector
so let me write it down this is 90
degrees
clockwise
and then we can think about what 90
degree counterclockwise
counter
clockwise would look like
if you're going counterclockwise your
original 1 0 vector right over here is
going to go over here it's going to
become
the 0 1 vector so we would write that
right over here
and then the 0 1 vector will then become
this vector if you're doing a 90 degree
counterclockwise rotation it's going to
become the negative 1 0 vector negative
1 0 vector so in theory these two
transformations should undo each other
if i do a transformation that first gets
90 degrees clockwise and then i apply a
transformation that's 90 degrees
counterclockwise i should get back to
where we began
now let's see what happens when we
compose these two transformations and we
know how to do that we've already talked
about it we essentially
multiply these two matrices
if we were to multiply
0 negative 1 1 0
times
0 negative 1 1 0
what do we get
well let's see
these this top left this is composing
two two by two matrices is equivalent to
multiplying them we've seen that in
other videos and so first we will look
at this row and this column and that's
going to be
0 times 0 plus 1 times 1 so that is
going to be 1. then we're going to look
at this row and this column
so 0 times negative 1 plus 1 times 0 is
just going to be 0
and then
we are going to multiply this row times
each of those columns so negative 1
times 0
is 0 plus 0 times 1 is 0
and then negative 1 times negative 1 is
1 plus 0 times 0 is 1.
and look what happened when we took the
composition of these two matrices that
should undo each other we see that it
does it turns into the identity
transformation or the identity matrix we
know that this matrix right over here as
a transformation is just going to map
everything on to their cells
now this is really interesting because
if we view these two by two
transformation matrices as functions
we've just shown that if we call this
say our first function then we could
call this its inverse and actually we
use that same language when we talk
about matrices if we call this as being
equal to a we would call this as being
equal to a inverse so if i were to take
matrix a and i were to multiply that
times its inverse
i should get the identity matrix which
is right over here and here i'm speaking
in generalities i'm not even just
talking about the 2x2 case this should
be the 3x3 case the 4x4 case so on and
so forth and we also know that i could
have defined this bottom one as a and
the top one is a inverse and so the
other way should be true as well a
inverse times a should also be
equivalent to the identity matrix and so
that's completely analogous to what we
saw in these function examples between a
function and its inverse because the
other day as we said an n by n matrix
can be viewed as a transformation can be
viewed as a function
and we also see that it has analogs to
just how we think about multiplication
because here we could do this
multiplication as a composition of
transformations but we also can just
view this as matrix multiplication and
so if we take a matrix and we multiply
it by its inverse that's analogous to
taking a number and multiplying by its
reciprocal and we get the equivalent of
what in the number world would just be
one but in the matrix world is the
identity matrix because the identity
matrix has this nice property that if i
were to take the identity matrix and i
were to multiply it times any matrix
you're going to get the original matrix
again which is what we saw or at least
the analog that we saw in the regular
number world